Welcome to Cloud Minute!
Today I'm going to show you a bit about Stackdriver Error Reporting.
Like most folks I occasionally ship code that has bugs in it.
Luckily Error Reporting can help me out.
So I just got an email tellling me that there's a new error in my App Engine app.
I deployed a couple minutes ago so the error is probably related.
It looks like there is a division by zero error that is causing a 500 response.
I can go to the cloud console to get more details.
Once on the console
I can see that this error has happened nine times and that it's been seen in multiple versions of my application.
I can see the status that it's
causing and I can also see when the error was first seen and when it was last seen.
If I scroll down a little bit there's some samples
of the error that include a stack trace and some additional
information that might be helpful for debugging.
Usually in my process at this point I'd enter a bug.
And once I do that I can link a bug to this error by clicking this button.
I hope Error Reporting is able to help you fix application errors quickly.